I guess the one sort of rumor that has
been appearing every single year we
finally had it confirmed the I guess for
a while I was like the next-gen version
of Skyrim or the HD version of scar what
they've actually gone for is Skyrim
special edition is the playstation 4 and
xbox one and mods are coming as well it
looks great first of all right Mike what
did you think of it yeah it looks
awesome I mean it looks good on pc right
now yeah but just the fact that you're
tapping into the console audience who I
think I think Dave the other day in the
lobby had said I think more morwen
deserves hmm a remaster a little more
because that's a overlooked game but
this is still people are still riding
like they're people that still play
Skyrim it's enough in recent memory that
people would be like oh that's perfect
this is the perfect kind of jump back in
having a mods is huge right but also I'm
it's a special edition it's gonna have
like mushrooms it's going to have the
like all the DLCs rise okay gaping me
right now there's like four of them
books buy this footage it looks awesome
yeah look at solitude there looks
incredible and water stuff but never
realize that I wanted to replace Kyurem
until I started looking at you can hear
that many music right now kinda I'm just
slimy and the witcher 3 like last
expansion pack size by the time we're
done with that you want to get your
finest kicks on this is gonna be the
perfect thing i come around october 26th
is when it's coming ash october is
stacked like so many games coming in and
then we're expected to play skyrim again
battlefield titanfall i didn't fall to
this many others lot of girls I just
know it I can just see I can sense my
google calendar it's just like crammed
full of games at the moment so that's a
very very exciting 1 i'm great that they
finally have it out as well it's been
the worst really badly kept room for a
while so like it's done okay honey done
a little bit sad that we didn't see any
other ellis cose stuff yeah it did we
saw the Elder Scrolls online we did see
a ESO accompanied by screaming stream
lady yeah you're right there was one
lady in the front row a little bit too
much skooma cuz she was serious waited
the whole segment was the most
long-winded way to say hello I still
exist do you remember we
game there was a surprising amount of
people in the probably still are there
in the twit shot on the game spot shot
saying I'm only here for my maybe the
trolling maybe that yeah I thought about
it for half a second and actually a mile
this ain't a'no they also actually
showed off Elder Scrolls legends which I
mean I never I never got to find out
what happened to the moth priest because
the stream bro yeah during their
presentation there's writing the I feel
like they're writing the hearthstone
Gwen fad yeah mmm yeah which-which the
hearthstone very good when is a little
more shallow but it's still good and no
well yeah what up to see it happened
that if the rumors of CD projekt red's
standalone Gwen thing are to be believed
I mean there's a massive poster us it
kinda looks like it might be literally
is a grim card so if it doesn't I'm
gonna be like you wasted some money I'd
be like expert love okay